bonsoir huit heures de discussions où en
sommes-nous
stéphanie bien les discussions pour la
journée sont terminés ou en tout cas en
pause parce que les deux vice ministre
des affaires étrangères tiennent
actuellement des conférences de presse
distinctes
donc voilà c'est la troisième fois que
ces délégations américaine et russe se
rencontraient à genève dans le cadre du
dialogue sur la sur la sécurité
stratégique entamée après le sommet de
juin dernier entre les présidents by
downloading routine et donc sans
surprise il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
beaucoup d'avancé le dialogue est
difficile entre les deux parties selon
les propos du vice ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï ryabkov qui
s'expriment actuellement en ce moment
ici à la mission russe à genève et et
car il faut dire que le contexte est
particulièrement tendue comme vous
l'avez dit avec la situation en ukraine
qui continue de cristalliser les
désaccords entre les deux pays les
etats-unis appelle moscou a retiré les
quelque cent mille militaires postés à
la frontière tandis que la russie
affirme qu'elle ne compte pas envahir
l'ukraine mais elle dit qu'elle ne fera
aucune concession tant que les états
unis ne s'engagent pas sur le fait sur
un nom expansion de l'otan et sur le
fait que l'ukraine ne fera pas partie
c'est un point très important pour les
vice ministres des affaires étrangères
qui l'a répété encore conférence de
rodez alors des propos qui sont
évidemment irrecevables par les états
unis qui menacent eux la russie de
sanctions bref le statu quo perdure pour
l'instant mais les discussions
continuent et elles vont aussi continuer
à bruxelles mercredi à l'otan et à
vienne ce mercredi avec le sc eux